herzlich willkommen zum wohnungsprojekt
nummer 7 dem projekt indem ich eine
wohnung kaufen sie raus kreise renoviere
und nach meinen und euren träumen umbau
das rausreißen hat endlich ein ende wir
sind am wiederaufbau angekommen von
elektroplanung über neue wasserleitungen
und neue wände ist in dieser folge so
ziemlich alles mit dabei ich wünsche
euch viel spaß folge nummer 7
bevor es so richtig losgeht vergesst
nicht den kanal zu abonnieren um
keinster folgenden videos zu verpassen
und mich zu supporten man munkelt auch
dass in den nächsten wochen endlich
wieder mit hilfe der löwen weitergeht
und euch jetzt viel spaß mit diesem
video
anstinken auch
angefangen haben wir damit die komplette
elektronik neu zu planen und jahr zum
dritten mal wir haben uns tatsächlich
immer mal wieder mit der elektro firma
getroffen und das alles wieder neu
geplant wenn es ist natürlich wichtig
dass die lichtschalter und steckdosen
genau dort sind wo wir sie in der neuen
wohnungs aufteilung braucht selbes gilt
natürlich für mein handy selbes gilt
natürlich für beleuchtung in der
gesamten wohnung und im bad und weitere
tolle dinge für die wir uns besondere
sachen einfallen lassen mussten denn wir
erinnern uns an die letzte folge jetzt
ist auch nur die frage
[Musik]
was genau wir uns dann aber haben
einfallen lassen und was wir dann auch
in dieser folge noch direkt umgesetzt
haben erfahrt ihr später es geht endlich
weiter im wohnungsprojekt tatsächlich
können wir obwohl es mit dem wasser
nicht weitergeht mit der elektrik weiter
machen und dafür habe ich mir die
absolut professionelle unterstützung
geholt wenn ihr an euren liebling
streetwear laden in deutschland
vielleicht sogar im ausland denkt dann
hatte diese firma mit ziemlicher
sicherheit ihre finger im spiel alex
wird nicht mit
hier in der wohnung unterstützen wir
haben uns kranke sachen überlegt und in
den nächsten tagen werden alex und seine
kollegen bei mir in der wohnung hier
alles umbauen geplant ist schon alles
und dann kann es morgen damit losgehen
das verbände aus schlitz neue leitungen
neue verteilung und so verlegt und
natürlich morgen auch ein bisschen zu
wort kommen lassen damit ihr erklären
können warum ist vielleicht schlaues
profis dazu zu holen wie ich auch schon
immer gesagt hat bei elektrik und wasser
da vielleicht lieber die profis ran das
heißt
können sie böse dann geht's morgen
tatsächlich endlich weiter nach sieben
tagen stillstand und es gibt aber auch
an anderer stelle noch sehr gute news
[Musik]
naja die firma die elektro und
lichtplanung komplett mit und für mich
macht nennt sich systems und ich bin
unendlich dankbar dass sie sich erbarmt
haben nicht bei diesem so winzigen
projekt zu unterstützen
tatsächlich haben sie gesagt dass sie in
so eine kleine wohnung noch nie so viel
arbeit gesteckt haben das freut mich
natürlich um zum anderen weiß ich es
umso mehr zu schätzen dass sie sich
dieses projekt angenommen haben
eigentlich machen sie so was hier also
wirklich absolut top notch arbeit wenn
ihr irgendwas einrichtungen
elektroplanung elektro umsetzungen
lichtplanung und so weiter für neubauten
oder bestandsimmobilien braucht dann ist
das auf jeden fall die richtige firma
für euch alle links und kontaktdaten
findet ihr ein video beschreibung auch
hier nochmal persönlich alex vielen dank
dass du mit so viel herzblut mit mir an
diesem projekt arbeitet und das so krass
macht vielen vielen dank euch viel spaß
weiter mit dem video des weiteren gibt
es eine menge dinge die mir vorher gar
nicht bewusst waren um im bad einen
regen dusche zu installieren brauchen
wir einen größeren durchlass nicht sein
um einen größeren durchlauferhitzer
installieren zu können brauchen wir eine
höher abgesicherte leitung um eine
höhere abgesicherte leitung an zu
bringen brauchen einen neuen
schaltschrank weil der aktuelle
schaltschrank zu wenig platz hat hier in
unserer alter schaltschrank der hat so
15 cm ausgeguckt die tür ist dagegen
geschlagen das ist natürlich völliger
quatsch das wollten wir nicht haben uns
hier dran geklemmt aufgeschlitzt
komplett durch die gesamte wohnung die
ganzen halten steckdosen werden weiter
benutzt hier wurde weiter geschwitzt ins
party night höchstadt einmal nach oben
für indirekte beleuchtung hier strom für
die spiegel beleuchtung dann durch die
wand zu unserem neuen schaltschrank ein
absoluter traum wunderbar hier mit effi
muss aufgrund verordnung jetzt eben was
einen sprung gemacht wird immer
eingebaut werden fg ist auch super
sinnvoll heißt
das hier und bedeutet einfach ihr packt
in die steckdose und der strom geht aus
und euch passiert nichts das ist sehr
gut und hier haben sogar neue steckdosen
die unser fernsehprogramm lösen hier
kann nämlich jetzt
und wir wollen an die wand allgemein hat
sich überlegt weil ich auch verstehen
wollte euch einmal komplett zu erklären
wie das mit der elektrik genau
funktioniert das ding ist das ist ein
geschützter beruf und das auch mit grund
damit ist nicht zu spaßen und ich sehe
mich eigentlich nicht in der position
mir dass irgendwo im internet selber so
ein bisschen zusammen zu suchen und euch
dann davon zu erzählen auch hier gibt es
wieder vernünftige youtube-kanäle die
weiter ins detail gehen wenn euch das
interessiert das hier ist einer davon
die links dazu alle in der video
beschreibung in absprache mit unserem
schreiner der ja eine komplette
einbaulösung für die wohnung bastelt für
einbauschrank einbauküche ein bett und
so weiter haben uns dazu entschlossen so
ziemlich alles was uns in der wohnung so
stört im einbauschrank verschwinden zu
lassen also neuer schaltschrank neuer
und größerer durchlauferhitzer und der
neue hauptwache abschluss hatte mal was
für ein haupt wasser abschluss bis dato
hatten wir doch noch gar keine ansage
vom hausverwalter ja das stimmt
tatsächlich hat sich aber kurze zeit
nach der veröffentlichung des letzten
videos der hausverwalter gemeldet und
endlich sein google geben aber nicht nur
einen neuen haupt wasser abschluss
sondern auch eine steigleitung was mega
geil ist weil wir dadurch wirklich für
die nächsten 20 25 30 jahre wieder
komplett ruhe haben und die wände guten
gewissens wieder zumachen können damit
die sak jungs jetzt aber auch wirklich
die steigleitung austauschen können und
gleichzeitig den haupt wasseranschluss
verlegen denn wir wollen ihn nicht mehr
im bad haben das soll ja alles in clean
im look sein wir wollen ihnen jetzt in
den einbauschrank verlegen also er soll
an anderen positionen dafür muss ich
aber jetzt eine trockenbauwand ziehen
das habe ich auch schon mal gemacht mit
tobi also unterstützung von malermeister
uw profil auf dem boden und an die decke
die profile ein 62 zentimeter
voneinander weg begibt platten rein dann
noch so trittschalldämmung unten drunter
und so weiter ob ich das jetzt alleine
hinbekommen werden wir schauen ob ich
mir dass alles gut gemerkt habe ich bin
gespannt
[Musik]
die band ist ja komplett der bahn läuft
so weg
jetzt hier irgendwie profil sie kommen
quasi auf dem boden und an die decke die
anderen profile werden dann gleich
wieder senkrecht eingestellt wer jetzt
hier auf einer linie jetzt können wir
jedes einfach mal so basis halber
ausrichten aber so wird dann hier stehen
hast doch schon ziemlich gut aber damit
die nachbarn jetzt nicht von meinen
mietern oder potenziell irgendwem von
euch alles mitbekommen werden wir jetzt
noch trittschall darunter kleben und im
prinzip können wir dann die umwelt
profile festwochen und dann damit
anfangen das wirkliche stellen kriegt
ihr einzuziehen und dann zu geplanten
time lab
und ein sehr einfacher kleiner trick wir
haben 40 mm lange dübel woher wissen wir
also dass wir nicht unnötig tief bohren
messen uns vorher einfach die
beauty-queen
hallo wir müssen uns vorher einfach den
bohrer auf 40 mm ab bekommt mehr los ist
weiter als wendig und dann waren wir
einfach genau bis zum klebeband
sollte versteht schon
[Musik]
die profile oben und unten steht jetzt
nehmen wir zb profil in zwei meter
sechzig lang so viel deckenhöhe haben
wir gar nicht ich möchte jetzt mit dem
lasermessgerät immer genau an der stelle
wie hoch die decke ist das wird sich
hoffentlich über diese zwei meter jetzt
nicht zu viel ändern damit messen wir
die zwei zentimeter ab damit würde noch
vernünftig hin und her verschieben
können und dann wird es geklemmt und
dann können wir im prinzip anfang den
ganzen lachs mit regierung allgemein
schaut euch das nicht von mir ab ich
glaube kreativ tun wie vor bei allen
leuten die das professionell machen bei
mir ist nur von youtube-videos gelernt
von irgendwelchen leuten gelernt und
einfach wiederholt also ich mag
bestimmbarkeit
2497 millimeter zwei zentimeter ab 2000
muss jetzt auch nicht 100 prozent genau
[Musik]
ich stelle mir das so
kurz abgeschnitten
wie konnte ich mich davon
ab
[Musik]
aber mein lieblings part das ganze wir
sind hierzu gespräch sondern immer mehr
zahlen das habe ich im büro schon
ziemlich viel gemacht und ist nun
verstehen wie die ausgeht
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde wie ihr seht das
ständerwerk steht und jetzt kann man
damit anfangen die rigips platten
überall dran zu ballern ganz wichtig
keine kreuzungen die platten müssen
immer wieder versetzt sein ich starte
jetzt einfach hier und weil die dinger
durch
eine versenkt sei mit der maler nicht
sauer wird dir das hier nachher alles
verputzt und verspachtelt also das
bedeutet werden bekommt muss richtig
quasi versunken sein der maler ist
wirklich einfach und ich bekomme nicht
auf den deckel vor vier monaten habe ich
aus witz gedacht ich brauche das büro
einfach im jetzt stehe ich hier in
meiner eigenen projekt wohnungen und hat
die wand komplett alleine gezogen also
das ist kein witz wenn ich sage das
begeistert mich wirklich das handwerk zu
lernen das ist einfach unheimlich geil
und auch die kooperationen bayerischen
handwerks tragt wo zu drei videos kamen
kamen wirklich von herzen ich will euch
für suntech begeistern das ist richtig
geil und klar ich habe schon einige
kommentare gesehen ja mach das mal 40
jahre lang bleibt einfach zu sagen klar
ich weiß nicht wie es ist dass fünf tage
die woche für die nächsten 40 jahre zu
machen aber ich glaube dass wirklich
wichtig ist dass sich jeder damit in
irgendeiner weise mal auseinandersetzt
es einfach ausprobiert und dann guckt
inwieweit es ihm spaß macht ob es für
ein job reicht und ob man es einfach vor
mäßig macht so wie ich es ist auf jeden
fall geil das ist komplett und verlinkt
und man sieht was man macht wichtig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das hat jetzt wirklich anderthalb
stunden gedauert wir haben fünf tage
erfahrung nur richtig richtig geil das
steht hier alles warum wir das jetzt
gemacht haben und warum wir vor allem
nur eine seite flanken ist voll
kompatibel mit
dieses rohr hier ist ja kaputt wir haben
uns jetzt mit dem hausverwalter geeinigt
dass nicht nur das gemacht wird sondern
die komplette steigleitung was mega mega
geil ist weil wir den absolute
gewissheit haben dass alles was mit zu
wasser in dieser wohnung zu tun hat
komplett auf dem neuesten stand ist
dadurch haben allerdings auch die
möglichkeit den hauptwasserhahn womit
wir das komplette wasser für die wohnung
ablehnen können was hier eigentlich
wirklich kaputt ist aus dem rathaus zu
holen und das hierdurch diesem anzulegen
und damit im einbauschrank verschwinden
zu lassen doch nicht wird das bad
deutlich klima und der hauptwasserhahn
ist trotz alledem perfekt zu erreichen
außerdem können sich jetzt noch die
elektriker darum kümmern hier in der
offenen seite die kompletten kabel zu
verstauben wir haben jetzt erstmal hier
offen raushängen lassen und die werden
dann auch noch das verstaubt das ganze
wird noch gedämmt und dann wird es
irgendwann erst verputzt und nur damit
ihr euch das schon mal vorstellen könnte
hier auf dieser seite kommt die küche
aber nicht nur das ich habe mir noch was
richtig geiles mit dem tischler
gemeinsam einfallen lassen kommt hier
genetische kommt das bett und hier in
dem komplett offenen bereich wird bei
mir im wohnbereich sein und es bleibt
superheld es ist richtig geil wir lassen
uns den flur komplett offen und
allgemein wirkt es deutlich größer als
ich bin richtig richtig pump vielen dank
noch mal an markus für den vorschlag das
ganze so zu machen ich habe jetzt zwar
noch mal ein bisschen abgeändert aber
ich bin richtig happy damit und vor
allem es geht endlich weiter
[Musik]
als das endlich geschafft war konnte
sich die sak firma nun endlich darum
kümmern die steigleitung auszutauschen
dafür dass wasser in diesem kompletten
teil des hauses abstellen die alte
leitung raus flexen und die neue
einsetzen problem an der sache ich habe
nicht richtig zu ich dachte ich wäre
mega schlauer als ich die trockenbauwand
gebaut habe und gesehen habe das ist ja
auch deutlich schmalere profile gibt in
4 cm anstatt siebeneinhalb zentimeter
das bedeutet eine dünnere wand mega cool
und verliert weniger platz in der
wohnung also habe ich mich dafür
entschieden die wand so dünn wie krieg
zu bauen problemen die wand ist so dünn
dass wir keine leitungen in die wand
einziehen können an einer seite der wand
soll die neue küche entstehen wofür wir
natürlich zu und abwasser brauchen was
einfach nicht in die 4 cm profil stärke
reinpasst richtig richtig dumm und das
wiederum bedeutet dass die wand absolut
unbrauchbar ist und wir eine in 2,5 cm
mehr profil stärken brauchen
[Musik]
anderthalb stunden zwei stunden komplett
in den sand gesetzt aber
trockenbauwand mit siebeneinhalb
zentimeter profil stärke steht das
bedeutet wir können jetzt tatsächlich zu
und abwasser hierdurch legen der
stromkasten alles passt rein wunderbar
nun ja aus seinen fehlern lernt man
mittlerweile bin ich der schnellste
trockenbauer deutschlands natürlich
nicht im ansatz die profis sind noch mal
deutlich schneller und können es
deutlich besser nichtsdestotrotz habe
ich erfahrungen sammeln können es war
absolut bescheuert habe im endeffekt
aber trotzdem alles funktioniert es ist
jetzt tatsächlich so dass in den
nächsten wochen alle verschiedenen
gewerke wie uns jetzt noch dabei helfen
das bad weiter aufzubauen die einbau
sachen zu bauen den boden zu verlegen
und so weiter quasi parallel arbeiten
können wir sind jetzt tatsächlich
gefühlt im endspurt und es ist absolut
klar was passieren muss wer wann dran
ist und die an der wohnung weitergebaut
wird ich bin unheimlich kommt es gibt
ein großes projekt an dem ich teilnehmen
von dem ich euch aber noch nichts
erzählen darf deswegen nicht bald ins
ausland muss parallel wird aber an der
wohnung weiter gearbeitet und es kommen
weiter videos wenn euch dieses video
gefallen hat dann lasst ihn gerne ein
leichter vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren und wir sehen uns in den
nächsten wochen wieder wo übrigens auch
endlich wieder höhle der löwen kommt
macht's gut